we have Sam Sean in the studio Sam first
of all uh a difficult game out of the
opening he seemed to know the opening
better uh than you and then you decided
to sacrifice you went for this Knight to
B5 tell us a bit about uh the story of
that
decision yeah so he played this very
interesting line with Bishop A7 and G4
and I felt if I don't play Bishop H4 he
has very comfortable position after
Knight H5 Queen G5 so I tried to make
this uh Bishop H4 Knight B5 work for a
long time mhm uh I mean if I if I don't
make it work I think he goes uh like
Knight D2 Knight E7 and then Knight G6
that's right and I have I have to give
my dark C Bishop so I think this works
out but you can go Knight to H4 Knight
to H4 is another move in this position
Knight to H4 okay yeah right Knight H4
but then you know Knight H5 comes
and Knight H5 exactly yeah yeah that's
why I thought Bishop H4 was very
interesting U but I'm not sure it leads
to anything from the way he played King
G7 Knight
B5 Knight to B5 is the novelty and we
were looking at some ideas for black to
try to uh keep his extra piece in the
position one of them was this after
Queen sorry not uh Queen to E7 Rook to
G8 was an option did you spot this one
what was your plan I mean Rook to G8 I
play Rook ad D1 let's say right and now
Queen to E7 I have to go Queen E7
yeah I thought we could get this
position in the game I could have played
on after Queen E7 with Rook ad D1 and
then he plays Rook G8 I I think I have
to play something like H3 here or Rook
D3 maybe Rook D3 let's try Rook D3 Rook
to D3 I think what the the engine was
always trying to get was ideas of
A4 Knight A5 followed by C6 and Bishop
to
d8 Ah that's a very very nice idea yes
and if H3 is it the same uh idea the
same idea pretty much in every single
position yes this
A4 uhhuh and it's just saying that white
doesn't have a way to break through to
get to that Knight on basically my
position is extremely nice that he's in
an eternal pin but uh I I don't have the
Breakthrough like if you go back a few
moves uh if he doesn't play Rook G8 mhm
I mean we can look at the game so Queen
E7 yes check F3 he went for King G6 and
uh yeah I went for p after King G6 if I
play Rook a one here
mhm um he goes Rook G8
yes I think logically a H3 again mhm or
yeah H3 yeah and this position he just
stays in this A4 is very strong with
Knight A5 I
mean yeah that's the key idea but we
were really trying not to make this move
because it's such a crazy move yeah it's
completely on the other side of the
board you're just saying that okay you
don't have another resource coming
against uh that Knight on F6 so I'm just
simply going to do whatever I want on
this side A4 Knight A5 it doesn't come
to your mind right right right right so
I wonder if he plays Bishop D7 instead
of A4 and then I play A4 what's the
right yeah yeah this is probably the
best way to do it yeah I think the the
problem for me is how do I get F4 in
because let's say King G7 Rook D3 Rook a
E8 I guess makes sense
sure I just don't really know what to do
so King H1 just keep waiting I think
you're not doing anything and he's not
doing anything either it's kind of like
a stand still there was uh we were
analyzing after the game there was a
very interesting idea so if you go to
the final position Rook a D1 instead of
a Perpetual so King G6 Rook a D1 Queen
F3 King G6 Rook a D1 if you play Knight
B8 uh right away yes I can play D takes
E5 yes I'm not saying I have to here but
there's always this idea of playing
Knight D4 exactly yes yes yes yeah and
but the problem is he doesn't have to
play Knight B8 so it's this weird
position where we we're both stuck and
uh we don't really have ideas yeah
because if I ever try Queen G3 check F4
which is very logical um his Bishop on
B6 opens up got it it's not very easy to
continue Sam uh very tense but in the
endend probably the correct result
happened in this one congratulations
you're going into the rest day on a 50%
score uh that's a very decent score how
do you feel about your performance up to
this point in this
tournament uh I mean I've had some
interesting game so far and uh I I have
had some chances in the second round in
the end yesterday but I think
objectively it's it's been solid so far
solid so far congratulations we'll see
you after tomorrow we have a quick
question for Kate one one more question
for you uh Sam very quick question Sam
uh at one moment we saw a closeup at you
and I think after Queen takes F3 you
were like shaking hands and you seemed
very unhappy so was it because you
thought maybe the game is going to
quickly end in a draw or was there
another reason that you seemed very
unhappy uh I don't remember when was
that after I took on F3 G4 maybe after
G4 when he play yeah yeah I I did not
know G4 and I was not Happ
because you forgot the line that it
exists
or you were caught unaware by G4 I I
simply didn't know the move G4 ah so
that you were you were uh caught unaware
cuz we weren't sure that yeah yeah but
you manag it very well and I think draw
is a good result in this game very all
right Sam enjoy your free day all right
thank you absolutely as we continue our
l